hearthstone is packed with so many
different cards and characters that the
rumor mill is always spinning out of
control but now that Blizzard has
revealed the next expansion we can
finally confirm some of those rumors
it's called whispers of the old gods and
it brings a ton of new cards no surprise
there whispers of the old gods adds 134
new cards to hearthstone including the
four old gods from Warcraft lore I will
not even try to pronounce their names
but for 50 bucks you can pre-order a 50
card pack just like blizzard did for the
Grand Tournament expansion and for a
brief period of time after the release
anyone who logs in the hearthstone will
get three new card packs for free
opening your first old gods card pack
will also net you two bonus cards a
legendary and an occultist whispers of
the old gods will release in late April
or early May and the new standard in
wild game modes will launch with it
special quests and standard mode will
reward you with cards from the new
expansion there's certainly a lot of new
content coming to the game so stick with
gamespot to stay up to date for all the
blizzard hearth stone and virtual card
game news you need you're already in the
right place
Oh